looks like to have you in the studio I
love your jacket and you salon brand for
ages and now that I know that you have
the dance moves I've been you know
watching this music video this one's a
whole new world I was one of the 4.8
million people that have checked it out
oh my gosh thank you so much your moves
but let's start with Comic Con this have
you been before I have been this is my
second year okay
I think you could be crazier this year
ya know why because the movie wasn't out
last year and now it's out and yeah you
guys have a very exciting activation and
your fans are running around gosh you
run into any stars yet I haven't I
haven't been too busy I have been too
busy I want to meet the flash though
okay what's the money that's my that's
on my list for sure cuz Tom Cruise is
running around this morning Sally Cruz
is running around yeah he popped up cuz
the trailer he like showed the trailer
the Top Gun trailer for the first time
oh my gosh it's amazing up all over yeah
Chris Pratt's gonna be here on Saturdays
yeah I need to meet everybody yeah I'm
Chris Pratt yeah we got to go to dinner
yeah let's go to dinner
oh go to dinner they're gonna invite
Zach it's perfect oh my god Zach am I
invited yes you are like a bros night
you guys I mean everyone here is invited
guys Jenny can come great yeah that's
great
ice cream after two so like you said
last year Shazaam wasn't out we knew it
was gonna be a hit we knew it was great
but now the whole world knows it's great
how different is life now that you've
been in this like hit hit hit movie oh
it's it's insane it's it's been it's
been non-stop even going to like cuz it
was my first con last year my first ever
con and like even going to that and like
the movie wasn't even out yet yeah and
we had people like it was like it was
crazy like we couldn't even get through
the Convention Center so that it's crazy
I mean it's I'm so thankful for I mean
this opportunity and yeah idolize DC
growing up yeah I can't believe I'm a
part of this universe and like I said to
Zach and the press junket you know it's
gonna be a massive success he's like oh
I don't know now we know it's a matter
so will there be more I think yes have
you already started filming it we
actually stopped
how many of you signed up for third
don't know 47 47 correct answer 47 so
you guys yeah would you like to do more
shows ants I would love to okay yes yeah
I feel like you're trying very hard not
to break a contraction okay so the funny
part is I absolutely I don't I don't
know anything use exact stayed in touch
we have yes we've been doing some
signings at cons everywhere yeah that's
where we kind of meet up and it's the
best love you buddy
if you're watching this how is Zach I
mean not in like I love Zach way but
like how does your friendship with him
how is he doing after the fame because
it was his big deal for him to become
this exam as wow huge uh he's great he's
doing really well um I actually went to
that MTV Awards and I he was hosting and
he was so funny like great and it was it
was so weird because the rock was there
everyone you know he you know he's been
watching growing up was there so it's
really cool for him I mean he deserves
everything he deserves the world and I
mean now he's a superhero
it's we're dreaming about being a
superhero since he was a little boy and
now that dreams come to reality so I'm
at the MTV Awards did you get any
special treatment because he's like your
person like did he bring you backstage
oh my gosh I totally just sounded like
him no it was it totally does that voice
no but um all the kids um a couple of
the kids went and we had this table and
we were the Shazam table this is Sam
family is awesome this guy pretty good
really fun um well the beginning of a
lot of things for you but also the end
of sort of your breakout we're all in
Andy Mac what's it mean to you I just
watch the sort of summation video they
have gone out and like we'll always be
in each other's lives
[Laughter]
yeah how are you feeling about the end
of that era it's it's hard you know it's
really hard I've been on the show for
three years I've made friends I mean the
bestest friends ever I mean I've it's
it's hard no it's really hard but I mean
the show is such a special show and it
really it's you know there's never been
a Disney Channel show like anniemac yeah
and um I'm really thankful for Disney
for giving me my first real opportunity
in this industry and I'm just happy I
got to play Jonah back
the joy of playing in for three years
and I think we ended the show and I'm in
a really special way so well and Disney
is a big fan of you because I heard that
you are in the running to be princess in
the live-action Little Mermaid you in
its you have Harry Styles is that is
that true this is funny because I was
talking about that in the car
wow I didn't expect that really I didn't
know that you have no idea I had no I
know no I mean no I yeah running I guess
so okay it's good if you audition and
your name's being thrown around as the
top two contender we're doing good so
far
okay it's a good day what would it mean
to you to get that part though
oh it means so much to me on my first
show I mean I started off doing musical
theater so my first ever show was um
this was one of my first ever shows
which was and I was flounder and it was
really cute there's videos everywhere if
you guys want to look it up but it'd be
great so I would and I would love to do
the live action
no of course and um there's so many
amazing people that are in it that I'd
love to work with I saw that I think
Chloe just got cast is that right Halle
Berry Halle Halle Halle Berry hello
there that's right we both Bailey Holly
Bailey yeah yeah congratulation and
she's gonna be Ariel it's gonna be a
mess so you've screen tested with her
already so you know her really well yeah
you're excited about her being cast he's
gonna kill it because hopefully we get
to work together again oh man um so
close well I like it from superhero to
Prince yes I mean it's it would be all
the best definitely if it was gonna
happen and I get to work with my Disney
friends again right okay so just wink at
the camera if it's true and this is I
won't say anything
it'll be mute like just yeah I'll stop
pops communi um here's the thing I think
you'd be a great Prince Eric because now
I've watched your video one thought away
like I said over 4.8 million
views of this music video and you were
dancing and singing I was like am I
looking at Justin Bieber Justin
Timberlake another Justin like thank you
so much so are you gonna have time for
pop stardom
yes movie stardom yes 100% yeah I'm
gonna be doing everything yeah I just
got signed I just I mean one thought
away it's crazy because that was like my
first real single yeah I got Wiz Khalifa
on it somehow
insane I mean that was just a long shot
um funny story no story time I'll make
it really quick but um no I was in the
studio I recorded the song and everyone
was in there they were like everyone
that was in there they were like yeah
sure who would you want on this and I
was like Wiz Khalifa would be perfect
and of course everyone stared at me like
I was crazy yeah and um he one of the
producers I guess knew him and he had
was on the phone was came and recorded
the song a week later we got the song
back in like two weeks later it was
released so it was very fast process and
then we shot the music video yeah shout
out any leblanc
well yeah here's the thing though I'm
concerned for you I know Wiz Khalifa
very well and you are all of a sudden
your cute little you on the private jet
with Wiz Khalifa where is your mother I
know she wasn't there own sensors okay
good
yeah fun was that that was some like
baller stuff you were doing on your own
private on a private jet and some more
music what's like the next thing on your
list is it to do more music to focus on
that to focus on movies the next thing
that is brewing right now would probably
have to be Little Mermaid Little Mermaid
EP Shazam 3 Shazam - okay but like
actual record yeah EP yeah it's gonna be
coming soon I'm in the recording studio
every night a lot of amazing songs that
I'm super excited about it and uh a lot
of things in the works what's your vibe
like has someone broken your heart yet
that you you know that you can lament on
no nope just a player it's cute yeah
yeah I mean yeah I mean I am 16 yeah
things happen in life I mean I'm a
teenager yeah I'm gonna keep it keep it
for me yeah I love that one can we
expect the EP
like today September September September
okay maybe your whole team is like can
we go oh my god um well I'm so happy for
your horrible me don't forget us when
you know we're in the crowd with the 17
other billion people and good luck on
the final to Prince Erik thank you so
much bye guys love you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]